[Musique]
martin biron jonathan trudeau à la
castonguay bonsoir
à l'obus ce matin je pensais avoue
martin en lisant le texte de robidas je
passe sans voir le temps d'en parler de
monsieur prudhomme et j'avais dit allez
castonguay sur la pandémie
devrait écrire un livre allait vraiment
eu tellement chaud je vous redis
publiquement martin le mystère
prud'hommes oui il ya des choses comme
il ya une entente hors cour sera
difficile mais il ya un livre faire
alors je ferme la parenthèse puis sont
apparus à la fin tant mieux mais il y
avait un livre joue je vous confie seul
avortement on va écouter il ya eu ça
bouillonnait au québec hier ottawa
beaucoup aujourd'hui un peu mieux au
québec on va écouter monsieur legault
madame anglade et éric duhaime convient
pas normal est ce qu'il ne va pas en
avoir
moi je demanderais à l'ensemble des
formations politiques d'avoir clairement
des candidats qui ne sont pas contre
l'avortement
les gens ont droit d'avoir des
convictions personnelles les gens
devraient avoir une liberté religieuse
au québec et ses pots à monsieur legault
à madame anglade ou à monsieur nadeau
dubois de décider qui a le droit de se
présenter puis qui a pas le droit de se
présenter il ya quelque chose de très
intime antidémocratique c3 ou qu ils
sont en train de faire la promotion de
la culture de l'annulation al kanz à
coacher où on décide juste ceux qui
pensent comme nous qu'ils ont droit de
se présenter pour moi c'est un précédent
dangereux j'espère qu'ils vont revenir
sur leurs affirmations qu'ils ont fait
un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
on est passé de rock avec gabriella de
3,3 ou d'un coup est-ce qu'il ya place
au débat ou bon madame agréer monsieur
legault c'est clair 10 il remporte
candidat
pro vie anti avortement dans notre notre
équipe martin tour de tak bai c'est sûr
que tous les partis politiques à québec
aujourd'hui
éric duhaime qui a un candidat avoué qui
dit moi je ne légifère pas mais je suis
ouvertement pro vie
c'est certain qu'il ya une loi au pays
et les provinces qui de l'appliquer et
on voit les provinces l'appliquent
différemment est ce que c'est parce
qu'il ya plus de prouvy dans certaines
provinces que dans d'autres on peut
certainement soulever la question
si on pose la question différemment s'il
ya des candidats par exemple ouvertement
antisémite qui disent moi je suis
antisémite mais je ne lis je ne le jeu
ne bloquerait pas l'accès ou juif où je
suis homophobe ouvertement mais je ne
bloquerait pas le mariage gay alors
c'est sûr que les gens s'ils veulent
voter pour ses candidats l'ofppt peuvent
le faire ils peuvent se présenter sait
on est quand même dans un état
démocratique
mais la situation est que certaines
personnes veulent le pré vous prévenir
leurs droits et c'est ça la situation et
c'est ça l'enjeu qu'il est sur la table
aujourd'hui jonathan
soyons très juste pour commencer le est
clair éric duhaime ont répété à
plusieurs reprises que d'aucune façon il
était il était pro vie il est pro choix
que d'aucune façon il aurait l'intention
d'agir contre ce principe le qui est
fondamentale mais une fois qu'on a dit
ça doit aussi assumer l'image de son
parti projette l'état recherche de
crédibilité et résume nous parle des
libertés assuré mars et candide ont le
droit de penser ce qu'ils veulent lui le
droit de faire fi de ce dans le choix de
ses candidats mais la liberté sont aussi
celles des autres partis de critiquer
cette position-là d'eric j'aime et ton
parti et je serais même le parallèle
avec le fameux concept les concepts du
multiculturalisme et de
l'interculturalisme en un parti comme
celui d'éric duhaime va être très très
très critique du multiculturalisme
redire par exemple nous au québec on a
des valeurs communes oui on accepte
certaines différences monde des valeurs
communes une espèce de socle qui doit
être partagée qui doit faire consensus
mais je m'excuse mais lorsqu'on parle du
droit
aux femmes de disposer de leur corps du
droit à l'avortement
je pense que ça fait partie des valeurs
communes et je vois une espèce de
distorsions sont vus dans le message que
normalement éric duhaime pas sur la
liberté tout ça en tout cas il ya un
large large large consensus qui est de
gens qui va dans le sens de laisser aux
femmes le droit de 2,2 et de maîtriser
leur avenir et leur corps alec
mais d'abord les frontières du hockey
semons été repoussée je ne pensais pas
qu'on pouvait lier l'avortement au fait
d'être roi occupe toi au club je pense
que ça strictement et d'avoir dans le
débat mais c'est comme une espèce de
mouche pour tout le corps l'utilisent
comme un épouvantail tellement rien à
voir avec l'avortement mais bon avec
double utiliser une bonne différence
entre avoir un candidat qui sur le plan
personnel est opposée à l'avortement
pied enfin avoir un candidat qui en fait
la promotion ouvertement en termes de
militantisme et qui donc tente
d'influencer son parti il faut faire
bouger son parti sur cette question là
les croyances personnelles de chacun on
peux-tu te présenter en étant anti
avortement ça n'est pas ce qu'on veut en
faire sur la place publique est ce que
c'est parce qu'on veut changer la
politique du parti la politique du pays
où quelques j'aime mieux le savoir au
moins j'aime mieux que quelqu'un le
fasse à visière levée que les gens
votent en toute connaissance de cause
sachant les valeurs de cette personne là
non un parti est tout à fait droit aussi
lui dit nous on ne veut pas ce type de
personnes là
martine a raison on peut décider que ce
type de dépense de l'ordre représente
pour les valeurs du parti comme c'est le
cas pour dans d'autres domaines de
politique publique et ça en fait pas
quelque chose d'abominable non plus
parti politique qui m'arrive c'est tout
le monde n'est pas bienvenu il ya 10 des
valeurs yeux du chef qui décide d'une
organisation qui recrutent ou non c'est
tout à fait légitime de ce côté de
dominique anglade guergana d'autres bois
françois legault dubaï soit 6,4 ne le
sont pas les bienvenus éric duhaime a le
droit de dire quelle séquence de l'eau
sont les bienvenus chez lui s'il
souhaite mais de la disparue un lien
avec le wac isme nous ça j'avoue je
l'avais pas vu venir le passé on peut
être surpris encore en politique mais
c'est ça la beauté de la chose on peut
être surpris que trudeau a dit
aujourd'hui à jongler l'idée gels madame
je suis du clos de regarder ça de
légiférer le faux compagne à deux francs
et à l'accès
d'une part qui est problématique dans
plusieurs provinces au canada on avait
la carte tout à leur tête on peut la
voir et il ya le droit qui est plus
compliqué on a décriminalisé mais est ce
que c'est une bonne idée de légiférant
va coûter monsieur trudeau c'est très
court on revient je vous demandais ce
que ce une bonne idée de légiférer
nous sommes en train de regarder
exactement ce qu'on peut et doit faire
de plus pour assurer que toutes les
femmes ont ce libre choix à travers le
pays et en plus j'ai demandé au ministre
du clos et au ministre de faire un suivi
pour voir c'est quoi le cadre légal
qu'on pourrait améliorer
elle est qu est ce que vous comprenez de
la réflexion du communisme où et quand
on essaie comme on le fait souvent dans
les dernières années de marquer quelques
points politiques et d'embarrasser les
conservateurs dont on ressort les
promesses électorales la dernière
campagne on avait promis certaines
choses en matière d'avortement
d'ailleurs d'avoir plus d'accès ces
problématiques dans plusieurs provinces
atlantiques quand on voit les
justes excusez moi j'ai juste une
précision quand il ya pas de chiffres
oppose il ya pas de clinique dans l'est
on a donné par exemple en alberta y en a
que 5 c'est pour donner une idée aux
jantes en ontario trente huit cliniques
au québec 49 nouveau brunswick
s'inquiète pas de nous à lézignan il y
en a il y en a qu'une et du prince
édouard très peu aussi également en
nouvelle-écosse non ce que je sais c'est
que je pense que c'est une mauvaise idée
de légiférer sur le sujet au canada
actuellement ce débat là une époque
particulièrement pertinent on n'a pas du
tout le même système politique on n'a
pas des partis qui ont les mêmes
positions qu'au aux états unis si on
crée une loi autour de l'avortement ça
veut dire qu'il faudra fixer des règles
à partir de combien de semaines par
exemple on ne peut plus apporter et le
foetus est viable avec quelle semaine et
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour un parti
éventuellement de modifier un projet de
loi d'avoir déjà une législation en
place de deux mois je vais charger le
nombre de semaines je modifie par
exemple la viabilité du foetus comme on
le fait aux états unis la cause devant
la cour suprême c'est le mississippi qui
veut restreindre à 15 semaines le droit
d'avorter on peut jouer avec une loi
existant beaucoup plus que 6 ans ne pas
si bizarre à dire mais le faudrait qu'un
parti qui s'installe au pouvoir qui veut
légiférer là-dessus créé de toutes
pièces une législation afin que les
débats que ça n'implique pas mal plus
compliqué à faire donc moi je suis pas
certain qu'on devrait légiférer sur le
droit devrait davantage du ferry
légiférer sur la sélection devrait
s'assurer que tout le monde y c'est très
bien je n'attends qu'en pensez vous mais
j'ai l'impression d'entendre un monsieur
trudeau qu'il se dit que la meilleure
défense c'est l'attaqué
parce que quand on regarde joue aux
côtés de la frontière que droit que
plusieurs on le savait un peu plus
fragiles mais prenait quand même pour
air qui après quoi 50 ans après le
fameux jugement robert 6e wade on voit
ce qui est en train de passer aux états
unis donc on se dit nous au lieu de
reculer bien on va avancer on va venir
sécuriser sa je rejoins alec sur le
danger de légiférer sur des critères à
mettre en place qui après ce pourrait
être modifié parce que la raison pour
laquelle il ya pas de critères légaux au
canada c'est que ça bien été mises en
place c'est bien balisé on n'a pas de
problème avec par exemple les
avortements tardifs les hôpitaux qui ont
des comités éthiques qui vont siéger là
dessus des médecins qui ne sont pas
obligés de
procéder à des avortements s'ils ne se
sentent pas à l'aise avec ça par contre
donc sans nécessairement y aller du côté
de gilles hâtif moi ce que je ne déteste
pas c'est qu'on profite de ce moment
nous sommes là et du fait qu'on va
bientôt amorcer des négociations pour
l'augmentation des transferts en santé
avec les provinces les provinces qui
veulent avoir 28 milliards annuellement
de plus d'aller voir certaines provinces
et de dire on va ajouter non seulement
la carotte et le bâton c'est à dire que
si vous voulez plus ça va être
conditionnel à ce cas d'élise et à
l'avortement soit accrue quitte à ce que
même le bâton ce soit de couper dans les
transferts en santé on voit pas cette
réalité au québec parce que l'accès et
est bien établie mais dans d'autres
provinces et franchement plus délicat
france 3 plus problématique conclusion
martin là dessus mais il ya une
compétence des provinces en est la
compétence des provinces et de données
le service et de donner cet axe-là ça
pourrait être difficile pour monsieur
trudeau de légiférer directement mais
oui je n'attends pas tort il ya une
ligne aurait une feuille certainement
une façon en fait de forcer les
provinces à être un petit peu plus
proactifs et a donné les services quand
on sait qu'au nouveau brunswick le
service n'est même pas couvert ce il ya
trois cliniques elles sont privées les
femmes doivent payer pour ce service là
y'a un accès aux services de santé le
clip aux garanties dans ce colloque bon
très bien on verrait le rêve le rêve je
vous fais entendre monsieur aimons le
char les bons grand patron de la caisse
qui veut dire à québec hier je comprends
pas il ya un mois nous disait tout
allait bien on lui avait trouvé à la
mairesse de montréal une place autour de
la table décisionnelle or elle a appelé
le gouvernement après pour dire j'aime
plus le projet je n'aime pas le projet
on écoute monsieur aimons la réponse de
madame plantes puis on revient
mais moi j'ai appris à du jour du
gouvernement qui avait un appel dames 1
re s comme quoi voulez faire un autre
projet les dernières conversations ya à
peu près deux trois semaines avec elle
on n'a même pas eu besoin de se
rencontrer et elle est ravie avec la
proposition écrite qu'on lui avait
soumis la veine classe e la table
pour répondre à votre question ce qui
changeait louette à repenser non et dans
ce dossier là en fait ces deux éléments
très très distinctes niort 1 la
gouvernance du réel de l'est et il ya le
tracé de m de l'est et puis dans le
premier dossier qui est en lien que la
gouvernance effectivement ça avance et
très bien et puis moi je lis joly dit à
plusieurs reprises d'ailleurs mais après
ça le tracé lui ai quand même des enjeux
majeurs
alors moi jusqu'à la dernière minute
même en disputant que le premier
ministre la cdpq était le constructeur
c'est lui qui faisaient leur m2 laisse
la nouvelle mouture
bon sur la gouvernance et dit joly dit à
plusieurs reprises nous l'avait dit ici
qu'il y avait des bonnes nouvelles à
venir il ya un mois mais c'était ça le
gros problème qu'elle présentait le
manque de présence de ville de montréal
dans la gouvernance le tracé était si on
est là on va pouvoir le modifier ou
l'améliorer martin
dont 24 heures plus tard vous amener
tout le temps dans cette saga dure m
mais c'est intéressant ce qui s'est
passé en fait monsieur monsieur m'en
faut comprendre la frustration de la
caisse de dépôt qui quand même développe
une nouvelle expertise avec le rem et
leur m1 en fait c'est un peu la mise en
bouche leur m2 finalement le mot la
pièce les expertises se concrétisait et
après on pouvait vendre à
l'international
il rentabilisé en fait ce
lorraine l'ex captif du renne alors est
ce que la décision de retirer le dossier
à la caisse de dépôt aura un impact sur
sa réputation à l'international
ils disent que non mais c'est bien
possible il la mairesse a raison c'est à
elle de décider ce qu'elle veut dans son
environnement et pour ce qui du
gouvernement du québec ou ci est
remarqué que monsieur émond ne pas
n'a pas mordu la main qui le nourrit les
n'a pas visé le gouvernement le bureau
du premier ministre mais c'est quand
même là que ça s'est passé et c'est
monsieur legault qui dit oui à la
mairesse pour retirer le dossier de la
caisse de dépôt c'est sûr que monsieur
legault lui aussi à ses intérêts il s'en
vend en élections il veut avoir un
projet qui est porteur qui fait rêver
veut avoir quelque chose à raconter des
promesses à donner en campagne
électorale mont royal c'est un théâtre
construit il ya là que je veux faire
plaisir là à laval alors ft tout est dit
que finidi pour oui je comprends mais il
veut pas de controverse et qu'une
structure au centre-ville en même temps
je n'atteins il peut pas faire avec un
projet parce qu'il y aura pas de projet
élaboré d'ici six mois le soyons sérieux
jonathan dollar baissait moi j'ai dit
que c'était du génie politique l'annoncé
du gouvernement parce que il l'est il
aplanit des irritants au centre-ville
bien sécuriser les citoyens de la ville
qui se demandent s'ils vont être encore
laissés pour compte et on ajoute à ça le
prolongement dans la région de laval
dans lanaudière est potentiellement sur
la réussite donc en campagne vont
pouvoir dire à bien des gens qu'ils ont
ils leur font miroiter des perspectives
emballante pour l'avenir mais sur la
dynamique des 24 dernières heures je
pense que c'était un camouflet de bonne
augure donc de bon aloi que monsieur
moreau servi voulait bon s'assurer que
la caisse ne sortent pas trop entaché
dans cette cette espèce de joutes
politiques mais une fois que j'ai dit ça
je pense que tout le monde davantage à
ce qu'on tourne la page je pense qu'on
est rendu là qu'est ce qu'on va même ne
fait pas dans la politique elle ne se
chicane pour sur la place publique
monsieur m'ont dit ce qu'il avait à dire
passons à autre chose le gouvernement
auparavant elles ont plus que ça perdure
parce que lui seul a la réputation la
cdpq et fera est affecté à
l'international belle tin man il est
celui qui bénéficie des habits et des
retombées lorsque la caisse fait des
bonnes affaires et poursuit la ville de
montréal valérie plan non plus le repos
avant un repos avantage à ce que ça
perdure parce que au delà du rêve de
l'ess viol de m
le premier projet de rem qui vont entrer
en service dans les prochains mois c'est
la cdpq qui va demeurer maître d'oeuvre
de ce projet là je pense qu'elle est
elle aussi tout avantage à ce que les
relations redevienne au beau fixe au
moyen du moins en apparence en tout cas
et quant aux projets
concrets
la mer s affirme alec on vise encore
2029 peut-être sous traitants
est-ce que quelqu'un qui croit ça parce
que leur faut que le ministère des
transports la ville de montréal stm le
rtm s'entend
j'imagine que des gens qui y croient
bien complet de gens qui croient au père
noël mais généralement non plus autour
de 5 ou 6 ans ma fille qu encore au père
noël peut-être qu'elle croit encore aux
gemmes de l'est j'ai proposé la question
mais moi j'y crois pas pas 2029 pour
2030 pas 2031 2035 je sais pas à combien
de temps qu'on annonce la ligne bleue du
métro toujours pas de pelletée de terre
qui a été fait et on se retrouve avec
les mêmes bureaucratie qui ont géré ce
projet là depuis peu près 30 ans à dire
la spm la rtm la ville de montréal le
ministère des transports nous savons
prendre important de ballons clair qu'il
n'y a pas actuellement peut-être un
bureau de projet phare si on ne met
quelqu'un une personnalité qui même ce
projet là qui peut aller sur la place
publique qui brasse et les choses de
temps en temps ça pourrait être bien
parce que si on laisse les mêmes
personnes qui planifient la ligne bleue
du métro gérer leur hymne de l'est il ne
verra pas le jour alors c'est plate pour
les résidents de l'est mais disons que
le projet pour l'instant est loin d'être
sur les rails parce que j'ai
l'impression que mes résultats
55 ans j'ai l'impression que si on avait
un dilemme entre un projet un parfait je
pense que la démonstration était faite
prochain parfait ou
pas de projet pour un bout de temps ce
tapis sort qui malheureux martin mais
c'est un projet que ce projet qui va
aller en campagne électorale les
campeurs campagne avec toi c'est après
mais c'est cet été alors il ya ce sous
le bras il est capable de vendre quelque
chose qui peut avoir un peu en fait
emballer
des gens m'ont rien les séduire et après
mec dont on verra on verra on verra on
verra les gens de l'est s'attendent en
tout cas tout ce temps l'or merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonnes bonne
soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit